préservé par miracle le restaurer ou
encore en ruine les châteaux fascine
toujours le public
le moyen-âge est un siècle de bâtisseur
cela nous a légué des moments
extraordinaires qui compte beaucoup dans
notre identité des siècles après leur
apparition dans le paysage
il demeure avec les cathédrales les
symboles du moyen-âge et du pouvoir de
leurs commanditaires seigneur ou
souverain pour philippe auguste la
construction des châteaux a été un outil
pour restaurer l'autorité du roi de
france
leur construction a accompagné
l'évolution politique et culturelle de
la période médiévale
des centaines ont été construits en
europe et jusqu'aux portes du
moyen-orient mais leur forme leur plan
leurs caractéristiques ont
considérablement évolué au fil du temps
[Musique]
il ya une innovation il ya une sorte de
surenchère aussi de compétition
construire mieux que l'autre plus
parfait plus original plus nouveau des
premiers retours de pierres érigées en
quelques mois aux chantiers colossaux de
la cité de carcassonne ou du château de
chambord toutes ces constructions
façonné pendant cinq siècles de l'an
1000 à 1500 environ le paysage d'une
nation en gestation importé de là on a
de multiples pouvoirs qui sont centrés
sur le château forteresse de frontières
comme à salses ou château royal comme à
vincennes
ces édifices auront trois fonctions le
logement la défense et l'affirmation du
prestige
ils sont donc les marqueurs d'un monde
en constante mutation
il raconte à eux seuls 500 ans de
moyenne d'âge
[Musique]
l'apparition des châteaux forts en
europe ne doit rien au hasard
au cours de la longue période de paix
romaine des premiers siècles de notre
ère quelques castrum ou quelques villa
fortifiée avait été érigé à la frontière
de lempire rien de plus on trouve dans
les textes en latin en termes castrum
ton castrum ça a donné petit à petit ou
castellum château et castellon veut dire
tout simplement le village d'onzain
termes très généraux et on voit petit à
petit donc au 9ème 10ème siècle
le glissement de sens entre une place
forte qui peut être très grande
une ville fortifiée et petit à petit ce
qu'on interprète comme un lieu qui est
effectivement fortifiée mais c'est aussi
une résidence est pas la résidence de
n'importe qui de celui qui exerce un
pouvoir
au 9ème siècle la partition de l'empiré
de charlemagne plonge tout l'ouest
européen dans une période de chaos
l'autorité du roi mais également celle
de ses vassaux les comptes est
considérablement affaiblie
les villa fortifiée vont alors devoir
laisser place à de nouveaux types de
construction
d'autant qu'à partir des 8e et 9e siècle
le territoire de cette vaste région qui
n'est pas encore la france est assailli
par de multiples invasions les hongrois
à l'est les vikings au nord et à l'ouest
les sarrasins au sud
pour faire barrage l'europe se couvre de
châteaufort d'abord dans l'ouest et le
sud de la france puis jusqu'en normandie
en allemagne et en angleterre
la féodalité est alors en gestation
les seigneurs émancipé d'un pouvoir
royal très affaibli se lance dans la
conquête de territoires mais il faudra
ensuite les protéger ils conçoivent donc
des fortifications constructibles en un
temps record trois mois environ
les modes castrale élevés sur des
tertres artificiel pour symboliser et
concrètement retranché son château il
fallait créer artificiellement une
élévation qui soit fait pour pouvoir de
loin et pour être vue de loin la taille
moyenne de ces tertres en forme de cône
est d'environ 30 mètres de diamètre à la
base pour une dizaine au sommet
la hauteur varie de 6 à 12 m créant une
pente de 35 à 55 degrés c'est là que se
dresse la tour haute de 15 à 25 mètres
en contrebas la basse-cour le plus
souvent circulaire ou ovale elle est
entourée d'un fossé et d'une levée de
terre surmontés d'une palissade une tour
porte en bois
peut-on défendre l'accès c'est là que se
trouvent les bâtiments de service
écuries four pressoir ou forge c'est
quelque chose qui est simple qui
techniquement est très facile à faire
on peut faire avec les matériaux tirés
du fossé avec le personnel corvéables à
merci dont on dispose aussi donc on n'a
pas besoin de véritables techniciens
pour mettre en place cette structure les
château à motte vont se multiplier entre
le 10e et le xiième siècle
leur défense repose sur la succession
des obstacles fossé d'alu palissades et
sur la capacité de tenir un siège
la tour accessibles souvent par une
simple échelle est le signe du prestige
et de l'autorité des seigneurs c'est là
qu'ils vivent avec leurs familles celle
d'ardres dans le pas de calais
construite vers 11120 comportait quatre
niveaux un rez de chaussée enchâssée
dans la terre et faisant office de celje
et de magasins à grains surmonté d'un
étage
composé d'une grande salle et de la
chambre du seigneur venait au dessus la
pièce réservée aux enfants du couple
seigneurial et celle attribuée aux
hommes de garde
enfin surmontant l'ensemble une chapelle
était réservée aux maîtres de la tour
on est aussi une fois de plus cela dans
le le symbole pour montrer au reste de
la population et au reste de
l'aristocratie effectivement on a une
empreinte particulière dans le paysage
à cette époque les seniors s'affrontent
au cours de guerres privé afin d'étendre
et d'affirmer leur pouvoir
les modes castrale vont donc se
multiplier en europe occidentale et
jusqu'en angleterre
elle représente l'autorité et le pouvoir
et permettent de défendre les domaines
des radia de l'adversaire ces premières
structures de bois efficace face à de
petites troupes de fantassins et de
cavaliers ont pourtant un point faible
le feu
les installations défensives vont donc
au cours des 10e et 11e siècle être
renforcée par l'emploi de la pierre
certaines défense est en ériger dans ce
matériau en lieu et place des anciennes
fortifications de bois
comme à restaurer le castle au sud de
l'angleterre en france larchitecture des
premières fortifications valeur subit l
influence des normands solidement
d'implanter sur un vaste territoire
qu'il considère désormais comme une
sorte de nations et qu'ils doivent
protéger des appétits de leurs voisins
c'est le risque permanent dans le
système féodal au début c'est de de
perdre sa légitimité parce qu'on est
mangée par un autre plus fort que soi
donc on se défend en l'empêchant
d'entrer dans cette quête permanente de
protection la maçonnerie va venir
renforcer le système défensif des
édifices dès le début du 11e siècle les
seniors les plus puissants et les plus
fortunés vont donc remplacer les tours
maîtresse de bois par des grandes tours
en pierre
le plus célèbre d'entre eux foulques
nerra devenu comte d'anjou à seulement
17 ans va faire construire une trentaine
de forteresse dont celle de loches en
indre et loire
l'une des plus anciennes et imposante
tour maîtresse en pierre avec une telle
construction foulques nerra s'impose aux
yeux de tous comme l'égal du roi et il a
le choix entre deux types d'aménagements
ça peut être un aménagement disant
stratégique mais ça peut aussi être un
aménagement d'une espèce de château
palais ostentatoire qui est l'expression
à la fois de son pouvoir et répondant à
son goût du faste de grands seigneurs
donc par exemple un donjon comme le
donjon de loches
ce n'est pas un outil de guerre il est
entièrement construit en pierres et de
plus en pire de taille dressé en retrait
de fortifications plus récentes
le donjon de loches forme un rectangle
d'environ 25 mètres sur 15
sa hauteur est de 37 m une porte est
située sur le flanc le moins menacée
les fenêtres sont et braz et étroites
sur l'extérieur
[Musique]
au troisième étage d ouverture plus
large permettait sans doute de passer
sur une galerie de bois en surplomb
offrant la possibilité d'ajuster un tir
ou de lancer des projectiles sur les
assaillants parvenu au pied des
murailles le donjon résidentiel c'est
quelque chose dont on a des traces à
partir de 900 à peu près en france avec
en général la salle basse ou de niveau 2
salles basses la grande salle qui
souvent aussi l'accès à la tour qui est
une salle de réception de représentation
au premier étage
et puis au dessus on a des espaces qu'on
appelle vie à caméra par exemple sombre
qui sont un peu plus privatisé et puis
souvent un étage plutôt défensif dans la
partie supérieure qui est une espèce de
salle des gardes et un espace de
surveillance la défense d'une telle
forteresse est uniquement passive la
défense passive c'est construire
suffisamment solide au est retranché
pour empêcher les incursions donc plus
le château
à défaut ces larges profond plus ses
murs sont élevés mieux il se défend des
incursions ça c'est de la défense
passive
cette défense passive est combinée avec
une défense en profondeur
la plupart des forteresses de l'époque
romane sont implantés sur des lieux
particulièrement inaccessible au
carrefour de voies de communication
stratégique
les obstacles sont multipliés pour
empêcher l'assaillant de s'approcher de
la tour maîtresse fossé talus ou encore
palissade
on installe le château dans un lieu
naturellement bien défendu sur une
colline entourée par une rivière qui
forment des obstacles naturels
face à l'avancée d'un éventuel ennemis
donc ont ralenti l'avancée de l'ennemi
on s'isole
on se protège et on conçoit un peu le
château comme un refuge ça veut pas dire
non plus qu'on fait rien du tout puisque
on sait qu'il y avait au sommet des
murailles des chemins de ronde depuis
lesquelles on pouvait quand même tiré on
pouvait gaieté voilà mais tout cela ça
reste quand même relativement passif des
obstacles des murs des fossés des
défenses naturelles nombre de tours
maîtresse construite au cours du 11ème
siècle reprennent le plan quadrangulaire
facile à bâtir le modèle anglo normand
de ce type d'édifice aussi appelé tous
résidence ou tour palais et la tour de
londres
construite vers 1510 sur ordre de
guillaume le conquérant ou le grand
donjon du château de falaise en
normandie
bâti au tout début du 12e siècle
[Musique]
mais les donjons quadrangulaire montre
vite leurs limites défensives leurs
angles saillants mal défendu créons des
angles morts deviennent facilement
accessibles aux attaquants ils peuvent y
creuser des sapes des galeries creusées
sous les fondations des tours ou des
murailles qui sont ensuite bourré de
matières inflammables afin de faire
effondrer mon mur et de pénétrer dans le
doute c'est tour carrée disparaîtront
bientôt au profit de tous ronde mieux
adapté à l'art de la guerre
ce sera la grande innovation généralisée
au xiième et xiiième siècle mais il
faudra pour cela attendre le règne du
roi bâtisseur
philippe auguste
[Musique]
dès le début du 12e siècle le château
représente bien plus qu'une simple
fortifications il est aussi et surtout
un espace de vie quotidienne les paysans
viennent qui travaillait pour entretenir
les murailles curer les fossés ou encore
cultiver les terres du châtelain la
réserve le maître des lieux y réside
avec sa large famille frères soeurs
cousins
les chevaliers s'installe dans les fiefs
attribué par leur seigneur où ils font
construire des habitations fortifiée
mais cette indépendance soudaine n'est
pas sans effet sur les relations qu'ils
entretiennent avec le suzerain auprès
duquel il s'engage alors vous avez deux
grands rites le serment de fidélité et
l'hommage vous allé prêter un serment
sacrement quelque chose d'extrêmement
surnaturel mystérieux qui vous dépasse
et vous vous engagez à ne pas nuire à
votre seigneur vous faites partie de sa
cour vous savez c'est une société où la
qualité d'un homme se mesure au nombre
des gens qui sont autour de lui qui le
servent
à partir de là on a de multiples
pouvoirs qui sont centrés sur le château
quand le prince est absent on rend
hommage à sa tour de la même manière le
roi de france exige désormais que les
grands seigneurs lui prêtent hommage et
jure de lui apporter aide militaire et
conseils cette organisation des
relations entre vassaux résume à elle
seule la féodalité la pyramide du
pouvoir se recompose la société
médiévale évolué
le roi qui avait tout perdu récupère
progressivement ses prérogatives
récupère le banc le pouvoir de commander
de punir et ses tribunaux désormais sont
les seuls qui peuvent exercer la justice
et ce processus implique de nouveaux
châteaux ou en tout cas conquérir du
château des seigneurs et les adapter
avec des nouvelles techniques des
châteaux encore plus gros encore plus
perfectionné sur le plan militaire
encore plus un préalable qui marque un
reconquête de territoires par la royauté
d'autant qu'au 12ème et 13ème siècle
période qualifiée d' âge d'or des
châteaux forts france et angleterre se
livrent une guerre sans merci un conflit
au cours duquel les châteaux joue un
rôle primordial
donc on a des entités politiques qui
deviennent plus puissante qui entrent en
guerre ouverte dans les années on sent
80 90 et cela occasionne forcément la
construction de nouveaux châteaux et
pour le coup la 2 place porte il ya une
innovation il ya une sorte de surenchère
aussi de compétition construire mieux
que l'autre plus parfait plus original
plus nouveau lorsque philippe auguste
monte sur le trône en 180 le royaume de
france ne s'étant guère au delà de l'île
de france actuelle
la normandie l'anjou le men ou encore la
touraine sont alors sous la coupe du roi
d'angleterre jean sans terre
philippe auguste va donc étendre le
territoire royal aux dépens des
souverains anglo-normand les
plantagenêts il va aussi et surtout
rétablir son influence dans toutes les
provinces tenus par les grands vassaux
il met en place une administration en
charge de la gestion du royaume
profitant de l'essor des villes qu'ils
rallient à lui et de l'affaiblissement
des seigneurs appauvris par les
premières croisades philippe auguste
comme ses prédécesseurs capétiens va se
lancer dans une vaste entreprise de
rétablissement du pouvoir royal
mais il ne va pas se contenter de
conquêtes territoriales
il va aussi couvrir le royaume
d'infrastructures militaires au premier
rang desquels des châteaux pour philippe
auguste la construction des châteaux a
été un outil bien sûr de guerre et
d'affrontement 2 place porte mais ça a
été aussi un outil particulier ou
services de son pouvoir de son autorité
de son image ça a été pour lui un outil
pour restaurer l'autorité du roi de
france
en tout une trentaine d'édifices porte
la marque du souverain à travers le
royaume quand il ne les a pas fait
construire lui-même il les a dotés d'une
tour ronde symbole de son autorité au
moins de juin 12 104 philippe auguste
est désigné roi de france et non plus
roi des francs
pour parvenir à défendre son royaume et
à le garder des appétits féroces des
souverains plantagenêt le nouveau roi va
faire construire des forteresses au plan
standardisés une enceinte carré des
remparts flanqué de tours plein aux
angles et de tours semi circulaires en
leur milieu
une tour maîtresse ou donjons au centre
mais qui se déplacera bientôt sur les
angles et murs munis de créneaux un
chemin de ronde cintres en l'édifice est
courant sur les murailles d'une tour à
l'autre et enfin une porterie et un
corps de garde solidement implanté à
l'entrée
le château témoins modèle pour tous les
autres se trouvent à paris le louvre
homme qui n'était pas la résidence
d'ailleurs des rois de france est plutôt
le palais de la cité mais le louvre a
été construit dans les années 11 190 et
c'est le château par excellence qui
introduit un modèle nouveau qu'on va
appeler d'ailleurs le château
philippiens pas référence à aux
constructions de philippe auguste et qui
résultent vraiment là d'une réflexion
particulière sur un plan type le château
du louvre occupait le quart sud ouest de
l'actuelle cour carrée après douze ans
de travaux la grande tour le donjon est
achevée haute de 31 m elle est entourée
d'un fossé circulaire d'environ 7 mètres
cinquante de largeur et autant de
profondeur les murailles de la
forteresse occupant un quadrilatère de
78 m sur 72 sont renforcées par dix
tours
un fossé rempli d'eau complète le
dispositif défensif la porte principale
est au sud tandis qu'une autre plus
petit fait face à la ville
le mur ouest est renforcée car davantage
exposés aux attaques de bâtiment adossé
aux murailles ouest et sud abrite les
soldats les animaux et les équipements
nécessaires pour tenir un siège
les deux autres murs sont simplement
créé de l'est
[Musique]
un puits profond et une citerne assure
l'alimentation en eau
alors le château philippiens reprend des
concepts qui existent dès l'antiquité
c'est à dire des plans quadrangulaire
des segments de murailles bâti à ses
hôtes avec des chemins de ronde et
régulièrement flanqué donc défendu par
des tours de défense
l'ensemble est entouré et isolée par
défaut c'est donc ça c'est un concept
ancien mais qui évolue aussi puisqu'on a
désormais des tours où se multiplient
les organes de défense active
c'est-à-dire les archères ses standards
typique de l'architecturé philippe yen
se retrouve au château de dourdan dans
l'essonne
sans doute la plus aboutie est la mieux
conservée des forteresses philippe yens
murat créneau et courtine chemin de
ronde courant sur les murailles porterie
munis de hertz et autres grilles en fer
et bois corps-de-garde solidement planté
à l'entrée et défendant l'accès
principal trop et d'art cher dans les
tours où les murs tour flanqué aux
angles des remparts et présence d'un
donjon qui supplante peu à peu les tours
quadrangulaire massive puis qui
disparaîtra au cours du xiiie siècle le
seigneur s'installant volontiers dans un
édifice construit dans la cour
intérieure si cette standardisation de
l' architecture des châteaux forts va
durer près de deux siècles elle se
heurtera vie au développement des engins
de jais dévastateurs puis de l'article
l' architecture devra donc s'adapter une
nouvelle fois et adopter des formes
encore plus défensive
d'ici là les tours standardisé par le
pouvoir royal équiperont l'ensemble des
nouvelles fortifications
[Musique]
au cours du 12e siècle sur le modèle
initié par philippe auguste
les architectes médiévaux privilégie
donc la tour ronde plutôt que la tour
carrée car les projectiles d'engins de
sièges dont les plans ont été rapportés
par les croisés ricoche plus facilement
à sa surface
les croisades et de façon plus générale
les échanges avec lorient ont eu une
influence considérable dans la
construction des châteaux à la fin du
12e siècle et au début du xiiie siècle
puisque les ingénieurs militaires
rivalisaient d'imagination pour trouver
des nouvelles techniques d'attaqué de
défense des places donc on re découvre
des gros engins de tir gréco romains
comme la palette géante les trébuchet
donc des engins à contrepoids capable de
propulser des blocs de pierre de plus de
100 kg contre les murailles et lé tour
des châteaux sept engins de siège
impressionnant pêche toutefois par son
peu de maniabilité et la lenteur de sa
cadence de tir
le trébuchet est aussi un engin
représentative de la guerre biologique
médiévale de la même façon que les
défenseurs je t'ai depuis l'est ou en
bois immondices et excréments sur la
tête des assaillants les tirs de
trébuchet aurait été utilisée pour
projeter des entrailles d'animaux et des
cadavres infectés à l'intérieur du
château à siéger dans l'espoir de
contaminer sa garnison
quelle que soit leur taille leur système
de contrepoids ou deux j'ai tous ces
engins nécessite de mobiliser un nombre
conséquent d'hommes pour les manipuler
il faut aussi les connaissances
suffisantes pour les fabriquer et
surtout les deniers pour les acquérir
les plus gros engins de siège ne sont
donc pas à la portée des petits
seigneurs souvent appauvrie à leur tour
des diverses croisade
donc il ya un effort pour attaquer les
places épaisse porte
et puis en contrepartie évidemment on ya
un effort pour les défendre une épée si
les murs ont créé des nouveaux organes
de défense des chemins de ronde avec des
mâchicoulis des dispositifs pour pouvoir
jeter des projectiles à la tête des
assaillants et qu'on retrouve dans
quelques châteaux au 12e siècle en
occident comme château gaillard mai
on voit seulement se développer après à
la fin du 14ème siècle à la citadelle de
château gaillard en normandie
réputée imprenable a été la fierté de
richard coeur de lion le souverain
anglais a accompli l'exploit de la faire
bâtir en deux ans seulement elle
constitue l'ultime verrou destinée à
stopper la marche de philippe auguste
vers rouen
il lui faudra d'ailleurs attendre la fin
d'un très long siège au printemps 12 104
pour réussir à s'en emparer
car château gaillard possèdent très tôt
les attributs les plus efficaces d'une
défense dite active
l'idée c'est qu'il faut que ça résiste
donc le fait déjà par exemple à château
gaillard de remplacer les ouvrants bois
par des mâchicoulis en pierres ce qui
était à l'époque une innovation en
occident c'était très nouveau de faire
ça il y avait des mâchicoulis en pierre
en haut de la tour sur des grandes
arcades et les murs était plus épaisse
surtout donc les murs du château
gaillard exemple sont très épais et une
grosse résistance mécanique à l'impact
balistiques et lesperon avait pour
vocation en cap tirs balistiques de ne
pas donner prise cirque une pointe
ça permet de chasser le projectile et
les petits festons les formes festonné
c'est pareil c'était pour proposer un
tir balistique quelque chose qui puisse
faire ricochet le projectile donc avoir
un moindre impact donc là c'est vraiment
une réponse
l'épaississement et les formes au xiième
et xiiième siècle le simple
retranchements ne suffit plus avec l'
architecture philippines la défense
devient active
le château fort peut désormais protéger
l'ensemble des terres qui l'entourent
car les hommes postés sur son chemin de
ronde ou embusqué dans son corps de
garde peuvent défendre activement
l'édifice grâce au nouveau dispositif
défensif ménagers dans les tours et les
murailles et à leur capacité de
déplacement sur les courtines les
progrès dans l'art de construire ont
rendu les fortifications encore plus
solide et difficile à approcher au cours
du 3ème siècle les cours de bois
vulnérables aux feux disparaissent peu à
peu pour être remplacées par des
constructions en encorbellement les
bretèche un petit avant corps
rectangulaire ou à pans coupés et les
mâchicoulis une galerie de pierre
courant sur le sommet des courtines et
pour mieux protéger l'enceinte
on utilise à partir du milieu du 12e
siècle les tours comme postes de tirs
élément fondamental de la défense active
c'est la torah recherche dans une tour
semi-circulaire vous percez aussi des
archères deux flancs et une archère
frontale mais à l'étagé au dessus on les
perd ce pas au même endroit
ainsi vous avez une couverture des
angles de tir qui laisse pratiquement
pas dans l'angle mort parce que la
superposition des tirs différents
niveaux en éventail permet à l'archet de
défendre à peu près tous les angles de
vue depuis la tour d'une façon active
s'est inventé ou du moins c'est vraiment
mis en place à partir de dernier tiers
du 12e siècle et philippe auguste va le
systématiser il va en faire un système
les progrès sont tels que la forteresse
peut désormais être édifié en plein sur
des terrains plats et découvert
larchitecture philippe yen va influencer
les souverains anglais pendant plusieurs
siècles
le château de douvres situées sur les
côtes britanniques assure la défense du
port le plus proche de la france henri
ii plantagenêt le fait considérablement
agrandir entre 11 179 et on 188 en lui
adjoignant un splendide onjon palais
dans l'est de l'angleterre
le château de beaux diam construit entre
et 185 en pleine guerre de cent ans
reprend les archétypes des forteresses
française il est établi sur une base
carrée mais ne possède pas de tour
maîtresse
[Musique]
ajout perfectionnement ou véritable
création les principes de fortification
de l' architecture initiée par philippe
auguste évolue encore avec ses
successeurs son fils louis 8 et son
petit fils louis 9 qui n'auront de cesse
d'agrandir le domaine royal
oui naf ou saint louis qui a eu à
batailler notamment dans le sud de la
france contre le comte de toulouse
il a fait construire des châteaux des
places qui sont devenus finalement des
lieux
d'exercice ne contrôle de l'autorité
royale en 12 148 le traité de corbeil
fixe la frontière entre le royaume de
france et celui d'aragon
quelques années plus tôt plusieurs
forteresses perché au sommet
d'impressionnantes falaise avait été
acheté par louis 9
afin de marquer les nouvelles limites du
royaume lors non aguilar quéribus
perthus ou encore puylaurens parmi ces
citadelles du vertige celles de pays
perthus dans l'aude est sans doute la
plus impressionnante
la forteresse daté de la seconde moitié
du xiiie siècle s'allonge sur une crête
d'environ 300 mètres et domine la vallée
de quelques 500 m
l'ensemble est composé de trois parties
deux châteaux et une vaste esplanade
centrale le donjon vieux comprend un
logis et une église de style roman
tandis qu'une seconde forteresse est
riche et plus haut en douze 142 permet
une autonomie totale en cas de siège
impressionnantes ces citadelles ne
possède pourtant que de très faibles
garnison c'est le cas notamment du
château de puylaurens perché sur son
éperon calcaire la forteresse n'est
défendue que par une vingtaine de
fantassins et une meute de chiens
comment si peu d'hommes aurait-il pu
intervenir en cas d'invasion aurait-il
eu seulement le temps de descendre dans
les vallées qu'il dominait en fait ces
citadelles du vertige ne sont pas que
des forteresses
elles sont d'abord des constructions
politiques les armes d'une guerre
psychologique
elle symbolise la volonté des rois
capétiens de marquer de leur empreinte
le royaume qu'il gouverne un croisade
albigeoise est une occasion pour le
pouvoir capétiens de s'implanter
fortement dans ces territoires qui sont
très loin du siège du domaine royal
initial donc c'est vrai que ces châteaux
dit de frontières parce que ce sont des
territoires convoités finalement sont la
synthèse très souvent de fortifications
ancien de lieux pouvoir anciens qui sont
pris et repris et fortifiés par les uns
et par les autres
carcassonne c'est le premier exemple en
fait c'est une enceinte du 20e empire
romain donc on construit sur cette
infrastructure une double enceinte selon
les normes philippe yen avec des formes
nouvelles avec par exemple l'emploi de
pierre à bot sage
de pierre dont la surface en parement
représente une une bosse rustique ont
fait des tours un peu plus grosse mais à
chaque fois c'est quand même la base du
modèle philippe ya toujours avec des
tours circulaire et des archères et se
doter d'une très belle construction d'un
très coûteuse mais ce qui compte c'est
que la forme la beauté est
l'aboutissement et les formes de l'
architecture soit une preuve de prise de
pouvoir du but du jeu dirait de
l'autorité du roi capétiens sur ce
secteur-là
le château de carcassonne hérissée de
neuf tours est un petit bijou de
l'architecturé philippe yens les
fortifications de la cité constituent un
ensemble monumental avec son rempart
long de trois kilomètres jalonné de 40
tours muni de deux grandes portes
cette vaste acropole domine d'une
cinquantaine de mètres la rive droite de
la rivière bow plus belles cités
fortifiées d'europe
carcassonne possède deux enceintes
couronné par un chemin de ronde
la première intérieur est appuyée sur
les soubassements antique
la deuxième est protégé par 14 tours
c'est un investissement financier
considérable parce que tout est bâti en
pierre de taille avec une conception de
la défense active
on voit des détours archère des archères
immense équipes dont les formes de tirs
peuvent être de 2,3 mètres de longueur
et en fait on sait très bien que
finalement pas besoin d'avoir des
archives de 2,3 mètres de longueur pour
qu'elle soit plus efficace
donc il y a une dimension ostentatoire
une dimension aussi de démonstration de
l'autorité royale
à travers ces constructions qui sont
aussi évidemment des déconstructions
forte
le choix du site de construction d'un
château répondait à des critères
stratégiques et politiques mais
également environnementaux le chantier
devait être proche d'une carrière et
d'une forêt qui devrait fournir les
matériaux essentiels au chantier après
que la forêt avaient été déboisés le
terrain à bâtir et arpenter à l'aide
d'une corde à 13 noeuds espacé deux
coups d d'environ 50 cm le maître
d'oeuvre trace le plan du futur édifice
des pieux sont plantés au centre des
tours puis sont reliés entre eux par des
cordes aux déterminants des lignes ou
s'élèveront les courtines la
construction est une affaire de
spécialistes aux fonctions et
compétences précises tailleur de pierre
maçons charpentiers ou forgeron répartis
en corporation
le coût de ce travail est élevé la
quantité de pierres de taille utilisés
dans la construction d'un château
dépendra donc du budget alloué par le
seigneur la taille du château dépend
largement de la fortune de son
commanditaire de terre dont ils
disposent des redevances qu'il peut
percevoir et puis surtout des paysans
auquel il peut se faire travailler sur
place
le moyen-âge est en siècle de bâtisseur
sept ans siècle où beaucoup de richesses
beaucoup des capitaux peu son parti dans
la construction des cathédrales et dans
la construction des châteaux
bien sûr cela était peut-être au
détriment du niveau de vie cela était
peut-être au détriment de la qualité de
la santé de l'instruction des gens mais
en même temps cela nous a légué des
monuments extraordinaire qui compte
beaucoup dans notre identité et dans ce
que nous sommes actuellement
il faut de 8 à 12 ans pour bâtir les
châteaux du début du xiiie siècle
pendant toute la construction les maçons
vont veillé soigneusement à la qualité
de l'assemblage et à la droiture des
angles il utilise des engins de levage
comme la roue écureuils dont certains
modèles peuvent soulever un poids de 600
kg
wouts a croisées d'ogives
poutre en boîte et grâce aux tonneaux et
mortaises fenêtre empire de taille
chaque élément du château démontre une
incroyable maîtrise
le chantier est donc colossal
conjonction de plusieurs savoir-faire
coordonné par le maître d'oeuvre
on se pose souvent la question des
architectes surtout quand on est assez
admiratif devant la qualité des
constructions
ces années gut sur croisée d'ogives ya
une conception et de la bord et de la
construction qui répondent en même temps
cette église
bien sûr il ya des architectes mais on
conserve pas leur nom malheureusement à
part quelques longs ce sont des inconnus
de l'histoire si les noms des
architectes médiévaux ont disparu leurs
oeuvres dont la beauté et la complexité
reste aujourd'hui encore incontesté
auront traversé les siècles
[Musique]
avec le règne de philippe auguste et de
ses successeurs le royaume connaît une
période de pacification et de stabilité
les châteaux forts continue néanmoins de
se répandre sur le territoire royal et
bien qu ils répondent toujours aux
normes militaires leur fonction
résidentielle se développe la quête de
confort devient une préoccupation
majeure pour leurs commanditaires
à la longue le donjon est délaissé au
profit d'un bâtiment spécifique un logis
construit sur la basse cour où réside le
seigneur avec ses domestiques
et là vous avez effectivement
l'apparition d'un espace beaucoup plus
propre à la résidence est pas là
résident de n'importe qui c'est la
résidence de celui qui exerce le pouvoir
et de ses proches sa famille élargie sam
mais ce nid et on a tout au long du
moyen âge ce qu'on a un peu appeler la
trilogie qui apparaît dès l'époque
carolingienne dans les textes latins à
où la caméra capella la salle d'apparat
la ola comme on dit en latin le hall
donc une grande salle au 1er étage à
l'étagé noble où il y a le trône du
seigneur où l'on prend les repas les
banquiers c'est le lieu de convivialité
on dresse des table sur des tréteaux et
après le repas on les retire que vous
avez une partie qui est plus privé on
l'appelle en latin la caméra la chambre
et puis un troisième dieu qui est la
chapelle
la chapelle est non seulement le lieu de
la liturgie du culte mais c'est aussi un
lieu de culture puisque on y écrit on
conserve aussi quelques livres c'est la
bibliothèque qui dans la chapelle dont
le château est un lieu de résidence est
aussi un lieu de culture en oublie trop
souvent
la lumière constitue un élément de
confort indispensable à la vie
quotidienne des châtelains mais les
premiers châteaux encore rudimentaire
ont peu d'ouverture ce sont
essentiellement des meurtrières au xiiie
siècle de grandes fenêtres en arcade les
baies géminées se généralise sur les
façades les moins menacés et des logis
qui sont dans la cour comme les maisons
des 12ème siècle que l'on voit encore
dans certaines villes avec des très
belles fenêtres géminées assez ouverte
et qu'on aimait profiter de la lumière
naturelle
même si on n'avait pas de grandes belle
vitre comme aujourd'hui on avait assez
tôt un des des vitraux quand on n'avait
pas des volets de bois des toiles cirées
aussi et puis en profiter aussi de la
cheminée des torches
les ouvertures se loge alors dans une
large niche percée dans l'épaisseur du
mur et pourvus sur ces deux parois
latérales de banc de pierre les coûts
sièges les cheminées sans doute les
éléments de confort qui apparaissent le
plus tôt
relativement modeste dans les première
forteresse du 12e siècle
elles atteignent des degrés de
sophistication dans les constructions
plus tardive car la cheminée est
synonyme de prestige la haute et souvent
décorées d'ornement les armoiries du
maître des lieux
sa devise des moulures des décors
richement sculpté parfois peint et doré
ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'on trouve
dans quelques textes rares comme dans
l'archéologie des preuves d'un certain
luxe dans les châteaux très tôt 1 et en
particulier pour tout ce qui concerne
l'hygiène et on a des exemples dans dans
des châteaux de bain privée de latrines
ya toujours des latrines dans les
châteaux après il ya la préparation des
repas des cuisines des lieux de vie dont
toute une organisation une distribution
qui se complexifie l'approvisionnement
en eau est une nécessité vitale est
l'une des préoccupations du seigneur
indispensables à la vie quotidienne elle
est encore plus en cas de siège
la forteresse doit être autonome perché
sur un éperon
elle possède des citernes ou l'eau de
pluie est stockée après avoir été
filtrés par une couche de cailloux et de
sable en plein toubon château possède un
puits qui constitue un autre élément
d'ornementation et de prestige les
demeures des seniors les plus fortunés
comporte un point d'eau dans les
cuisines ou des canalisations captant
des sources parfois à plusieurs
kilomètres
c'est le cas à vincennes château royal
par excellence l'eau est directement
capté sur des sources situé sur les
hauteurs de montreuil à trois kilomètres
au nord arrivant sous pression grâce aux
dénivelés le précieux liquide est
d'abord stockés dans un château d'eau
avant d'être redistribués dans les
cuisines et les bains de la forteresse
le donjon haut de 50 mètres entouré
d'une chemise avec châtelet constitué de
deux tours jumelles et d'un fossé est
intégré à une vaste enceinte de 1200
mètres de périmètre typique de
l'architecturé militaire du début du
xvème siècle le fossé fait 11 mètres de
profondeur pour 25 mètres de large les
murailles sont couronnés de mâchicoulis
posait sur une série de cornish
surplombant le fossé
[Musique]
construite en pleine guerre de cent ans
à partir de très 161 ses fortifications
caractérise parfaitement la dernière
partie du moyen-âge au cours de laquelle
le conflit opposant le royaume de france
et celui d'angleterre connaît plusieurs
phases successives de fortes tensions au
cours de cet interminable conflit
une invention va radicalement changer
l'art de la guerre et l' architecture
militaire la poudre à la fin du 14ème
siècle de multiples pièces d'artillerie
apparaissent sur les champs de bataille
et à l'intérieur des citadelles la
diffusion de l'artillerie comme et des
dégâts considérables sur les courtils
sur les murs d enceinte des châteaux en
tirant depuis un tumeur des boulets de
pierre plus petit que les bouley des
grosses catapulte sur une muraille on
peut faire brèche quand même sur cette
muraille aussi efficacement et l'armée
plus facilement transportable donc la
cuirasse l'enceinte château doit
s'adapter aussi aux canons naissante
dans un premier temps on se contentait
d'élargir un peu les archères de
concevoir aussi des ouvertures de tir
pour les canons des bouches à feu des
archères canonnière puis des canonnières
et puis petit à petit on conçoit
vraiment des tours dans lesquels on peut
installer des canons
si les premiers boulet en pierres ne
sont pas très efficaces pour démanteler
les murailles l'apparition des boulets
en fonte au milieu du 15e siècle va
changer la donne car leur puissance de
destruction et dévastatrice on parle du
boulet qui fait brèche vient d'éclater
sur les murs il fait éclater le mur le
cas non plus fort le cas non plus
performant lui il impose l'adaptation de
l' architecture du château partout le
15e
on commence à faire des fortifications
beaucoup plus résistantes en fait plutôt
des forteresses plus trapu avec des
tours dont les épaisseurs d'amour
peuvent dépasser les 10 mètres pour
résister justement à l'impact de la
nouvelle a retiré les châteaux vont
désormais être bâtis ou adaptés pour
résister à une artillerie de sièges de
plus en plus puissantes
de plus en plus maniable employant des
boulets pesant jusqu'à 200 livres
environ 90 kg et de 42 cm de diamètre
parfois circle et de fer ou entièrement
en fonte
un meilleur dosage des poudres assure au
tir une plus grande régularité
désormais l'artillerie est en mesure de
concentrer ses tirs sur n'importe quel
point du rempart et donc de créer des
brèches
et c'est la fin vraiment des châteaux
forts de pierre médiévaux tels qu'on les
imagine à la fin du xvème siècle plus
aucune muraille ne peut résister aux
canons
en nouvelle aquitaine le château de
bonaguil aménagé entre 14 145 et 482 par
un seigneur mégalomane sur l'emplacement
d'un château du xiiie siècle va
bénéficier d'améliorations capable de le
faire résister au perfectionnement de
l'artillerie une enceinte aux murs
massifs protégeant l'entrée appelé
barbacane un donjon en forme d'amande et
présentant une pointe profil et plus
d'une centaine de canonnières percée
dans les murs ainsi qu'un boulevards
ceinturant l'ensemble est protégé par
des postes de tir
installé dans les fossés et au pied des
remparts les châteaux qui prennent ces
formes architecturales adapté à
l'artillerie à la l'impact d'artillerie
avec cette très grosse tour d'artillerie
ce sont le fait de très très grands
seigneurs ou durs ou des rois la
confiance dans les châteaux ne faiblit
donc par mais ceux qui sont construits à
partir du 15e siècle sont très
différents de leurs prédécesseurs
ils sont de plus en plus enfouies afin
d'empêcher que les tirs d'artillerie
n'ouvre des brèches dans leurs murs
d'enceinte la forteresse de salses aux
portes des pyrénées orientales est de
ceux là
construite à la fin du xvème siècle sur
ordre du roi d'espagne
elle défend alors la frontière avec la
france
son plan général enough considérablement
et annonce les fortifications moderne
dont vauban sera l'un des maîtres
incontestés est un exemple de césure
c'est la fin du château fort
on peut plus parler d'un château
médiéval même s'il en garde un petit peu
l'aspect les dispositions c'est déjà une
citadelle avec des très grosses tours
d'artillerie aux murs très épais et la
défense se fait par des canons à
l'intérieur de salle voûtée qui sont des
casemates avec défauts des systèmes de
ventilation pour que les servants
d'armes ne soit pas intoxiqué par les
fumées de leurs armes donc c'est très
solide on fait évoluer pour des formes
plus plus trapu plus résistantes
le chemin de ronde a lui aussi été conçu
pour accueillir des canons et des tours
ouverte à la gorge sont détachés de la
forteresse comme autant de défense
avancée les murailles élargi à leur base
sont épaisses de 14 mètres et s'enfonce
dans les fossés afin de les protéger des
coûts directs de l'assaillant ne
laissant dépasser du glacis que la
partie nécessaire à l'artillerie
les fossés sont protégées au moyen de
canonnières percée au bas des courtines
en élévation ça ne ressemble plus du
tout un château du moyen âge on n'a pas
des hautes tours on n'allait tour qui
s'enterre qui ont des murs très épais
mais dans lesquels finalement les bouley
vont venir mourir plutôt que de faire
éclater toutes les maçonneries donc on à
l'enterrement de la fortification le
début de ce que l'on a appelé aussi l'
architecture bastionnée donc des
constructions de terre a certes un
échelonnement aussi en profondeur de la
défense en a plusieurs lignes de défense
on repousse les canons très très loin
mais on n'est plus ni dans la forme
architecturale ni dans les fonctions
dans le château médiéval la forteresse
de salses incarne véritablement la fin
d'une époque
les châteaux forts sont amenés à
disparaître du paysage de nation de plus
en plus centralisée leur déclin
symbolise aussi l'agonie du système
féodal
la disparition des châteaux tient à la
paix à la paix interne dans le royaume
de france
une fois la guerre de cent ans finit le
xvième siècle bien sûr il y aura encore
les guerres de religion mais
progressivement on n'a plus besoin de
château défendu donc l'émergence de la
royauté la naissance de la monarchie
féodale progressivement pacifier le
territoire et les châteaux dans leur
aspect le plus militaire meurt de leur
belle mort
redevenu le fait du prince qui autorise
et commande sa construction le château
se transforme en palais en résidence
d'agrément dont les beautés et les
fastes architecturaux symbolise le
prestige du royal commanditaires
chambord dont les travaux sont
supervisés par françois 1er à partir de
15 cents dix-neuf ans constitue le
parfait exemple
c'est vrai quand on visite chambord qui
est présenté comme le grand château un
des premiers grands châteaux de la
renaissance
on n'est plus du tout dans un château
fort un château médiéval et pourtant
c'est un château à part entière on
conserve certains attributs défensifs
comme la tour les créneaux les
mâchicoulis qui deviennent un décor qui
devienne un symbole du pouvoir politique
oui chambord est un château d'apparat
comme tous les châteaux de la loire des
châteaux superbe où le roi fait venir au
cip le savoir-faire de l'italie leonardo
davinci à demeurer dans ses châteaux à
la demande des grands seigneurs de la
royauté française
nous sommes dans un contexte qui est
tout à fait différent on est dans des
zones qui sont complètement pacifié pour
des siècles
dans le même temps les rois poursuivre
leur entreprise de démantèlement des
forteresses henri iv en fait abattre
plusieurs pour éviter dit-il qu'elle ne
serve de repaire aux ennemis de
l'autorité royale
tout est dit c'en est fini des châteaux
forts et des châtelains tout puissant
sur leurs terres une grande partie de la
vie des nobles va désormais se dérouler
au plus près de leur souverain à la cour
et louis xiii puis louis 14 vont
poursuivre l'entreprise de démantèlement
lui xiii louis xiv richelieu ce sont des
grands destructeurs de château puisque
pour eux c'est une volonté de mettre fin
aux guerres de religion et 2 instauré à
l'ordre monarchique in volonté
effectivement de mettre à bas
tous ces symboles qui sont aussi le
symbole d'un temps passé
souvent on se contentait de démonter les
créneaux les organes défensif les
symboles de la défense dans d'autres cas
les châteaux ont été complètement
effectivement démoli et les pierres
employés ailleurs à la révolution ont
détruit tous les symboles justement de
l'autorité seigneurial et les châteaux
étaient laissés à l'abandon certains ont
servi de carrière de pierres donc on a
eu un peu la mode des ruines romantiques
du 19e siècle
[Musique]
au 19e siècle le château se fait
mystérieux ou lugubre sous la plume des
auteurs romantiques tout un imaginaire
se développe autour des ruines couverte
de mousse envahi par la végétation
vision d'un moyen âge idéalisée et
romanesque
le château des contes enfantins projette
sa silhouette gothiques sur les
lithographies et dans les peintures
au dix neuvième siècle beaucoup de
savants d'érudits s'intéresse à
l'histoire découvre pas que les châteaux
les églises le patrimoine avec une
vision très romantique et idéalisée et
puis le moyen-âge un moment donné
redevient à la mode alors avec des
clichés puisque certaines familles
bourgeois se font construire des
chapeaux néo roman puis néogothique à
partir de 1830 cette date à laquelle est
créée la commission des monuments
historiques
un mouvement de conservation se
développent les châteaux sont alors
resterez dans l'intérêt national à
l'image du château de pierrefonds dans
l'oise qui illustre parfaitement
l'exaltation poétique de la mode
romantique démantelé sur ordre de louis
xiii
il sera entièrement reconstruit par
l'architecte viollet le duc à partir de
c'est une construction princière qui a
marqué l'histoire de l'architecturé
castrale royal mais en même temps ce
château il faut le retrouver et faire la
part des restaurations reconstruction du
19e siècle donc notamment des
réinterprétations de viollet-le-duc
qu'elle double lecture à faire comme le
duc avait quand même vraiment du génie à
l'extérieur il a fait vraiment une
reconstitution très fiable des
superstructures des duos des to et pour
l'intérieur il ya une grande part de
création assez libre mais justement
c'est un parfait équilibre entre une
vraie constitution fiable et une
création bien référencé de la part d'un
homme cultivé savant qui était aussi un
historien de l'art et l'architecturé
ces ruines imposante devenu un lieu de
villégiature de l'aristocratie sont
restaurés sur ordre de napoléon iii qui
veut en faire une résidence impériale
l'architecte viollet le duc va appliquer
sur ce chantier sa conception fantasmée
du moyen-âge cet édifice est un
concentré de styles architecturaux
inspiré librement de la période
médiévale le double remparts
les échauguettes les meurtrières
couvrant le chemin de ronde
le donjon et les huit tours du château
côtoient des gargouilles aux formes
étranges les portiques extravagant et
des galeries labyrinthique un côté
gothique au sens sauvage du terme est
très gore très dracula ça fait partie de
toutes leurs imaginaires contemporains
issus du romantisme autour du château
mais en même temps viollet-le-duc et ses
grands restaurateurs du 19e siècle avait
une vision très positive du moyen-âge
un peu à la chateaubriand c'était nos
racines c'était une période glorieuse
sens de l'honneur sens de la nation
esprit chevaleresque
tout cela participe pas aux mêmes
imaginaire et il y à cette volonté de
reconstruire des église néogothique mais
aussi des châteaux compères font qui
rappelle que le moyen âge est aussi un
siècle de bâtisseur
qui a probablement produit le plus grand
de construction qu'on ait jamais eu à
l'occident du moins depuis l'époque
romaine
cinq sens en architecture médiévale sont
là condensé dans un édifice relevant
plus du mythe que de la réalité
historique
pierrefonds et le décor néo gothique
d'un conte de fées pendant un demi
millénaire souverain et seigneurs ont
fait construire des forteresses dont la
beauté la complexité et l'incroyable
longévité fascine encore ils sont autant
de témoins d'une époque d'avancées
technologiques et de créativité
ces édifices resteront à jamais le
symbole du moyen-âge
leurs majestés architectural et le
témoignage qu'il nous livre sur une
époque encore empreinte de mystère
suscite toujours autant la curiosité du
public
preuve que les châteaux n'ont pas fini
de faire rêver
[Musique]